and welcome to Hannity and tonight a
major US Embassy hit with rockets a
shooting at a synagogue in New York and
calls for a global Islamic and tiata on
American streets and by the way that
southern border yeah wide open leaving
our country totally vulnerable to
terrorists now the president's mind is
elsewhere his big Hollywood fundraiser
that's going on today his 53-year-old
son is in major trouble the Biden brand
has never looked worse than now so don't
expect to hear much from Joe Biden in
the days and weeks ahead now over and
over again Joe Biden has been angry
demanding that Americans pay their fair
share he accused American families and
businesses of being greedy and selfish
at the very same time while his own
beloved Son he was not paying any taxes
on what amounts to millions of dollars
in income according to a Federal
indictment and this by the way wasn't
just your normal everyday kind of income
now according to a Federal indictment
Hunter was raking in tons of money from
Ukraine and Romania and China uh all
while Daddy and Pops was vice president
and gearing up for a presidential run
Joe Biden lied to your face over and
over and over again take a look Vice
President Biden there have been
questions about the work your son has
done in China and for a Ukrainian Energy
company when you were Vice President in
retrospect was anything about those
relationships in appropriate or
unethical nothing was unethical my son
has not made money in terms of this
thing about uh what are you talking
about China I have not had the only guy
made money from China is this guy he's
the only one nobody else has made money
from China that was a lie and now that
Biden's own doj has established that the
president is a liar I think the American
people you deserve to know exactly why
well well-connected people in China
Ukraine Romania Kazakhstan you know why
were they paying Hunter Biden an
admitted addict at the time millions of
dollars oh by the way with no experience
now we the American people we deserve
answers from this weaponized doj why was
prosecutor Weiss prepared to put all of
this under the rug he didn't he wanted
no charges despite what is a mountain of
evidence that he just now revealed now
it's if not for two Brave IRS
whistleblowers telling the truth and one
Delaware judge asking questions if not
for Rudy Giuliani his attorney Bob
Costello in the New York Post telling
the truth about hunter's very real
laptop guess what none of these charges
would have been filed now why is that
why were Weiss and Garland you know why
were they doing Joe Biden such a favor
were they trying to influence an
election do they usually give a a pass
to tax cheats now the crimes listed in
this indictment they are egregious now
Biden is accused of willfully refusing
to pay taxes in 2016 17 18 19 and in
2017 and 18 he didn't even bother filing
a tax return and remember prosecutor
Weiss he let the statute of limitations
run out in the unpaid taxes those were
the barisma years how convenient he also
accused of committing fraud by deducting
a sex club membership and porn
subscriptions as business expenses are
you kidding me now during this time
Hunter lived a quite extravagant
lifestyle according to the indictment
spending nearly
$700,000 on various women another
$400,000 on clothing accessories
$188,000 on adult entertainment whatever
that means another
$215,000 on restaurants and food and get
this he took out more than $1.6 million
in ATM withdrawals in other words Hunter
was spending Millions on quote drugs
escorts girlfriends luxury hotels rental
properties exotic cars clothing other
items all while dodging both taxes and
child support payments but in a newly
released podcast Hunter well he tells
the world that he and his father they
are victims a vast right-wing conspiracy
is now back according to Hunter
Republicans are trying to kill him take
a
listen they're trying to destroy a
presidency and so it's not about me in
their most base way what they're trying
to do is they're trying to kill me
knowing that it will be a pain greater
than my father could be able to handle
and so therefore destroying a presidency
in that way ah poor Hunter how dare
those Republicans demand oh Equal
justice under the law equal application
of our laws uh the president's what they
shouldn't have to pay taxes or file the
law well I guess not if you're a Biden
until now the bidens have been able to
do pretty much whatever they want now
the country just spent four what
hysteria filled years on Trump Russia
collusion The Witch Hunt that never
happened that went nowhere all lies all
conspiracy theories but hunter takes
Millions from the first Lady of Moscow
that's right uh millions of dollars and
no one bats an eyelash nobody he takes
Millions from members of the Chinese
Communist party and the media mob oh the
no questions from them as Vice President
we know Joe Biden interacts with
Hunter's business partners on a regular
basis we learned that this week through
phone calls through emails through golf
outings and dinners and what nobody sees
a problem according to John Solomon
there were at least six suspicious
activity reports detailing a whopping
$12 million in wire payments to Joe
Biden's Delaware home H what nobody on
the left nobody in the media has
anything to say by the way where is uh
Adam Schiff or Eric swell or Liz Cheney
or fake news CNN or msdnc or the New
York Times or the Washington Post they
accuse Trump of being a Russian plant
for four long years then they elect a
guy who is credibly accused of pedaling
the Biden brand to every sketchy
oligarch in the world including Russian
oligarchs now clearly there is a
political rot in our government our
media our our justice system today it's
now been exposed for all of sea hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else